to bring different parts of our country
together my government will work to
bring about a balanced economic recovery
legislation will be introduced to
provide for the devolution of powers to
cities with elected metro mass helping
to build a northern powers my government
will continue to legislate for
high-speed rail links between the
different thoughts for the country my
government will also bring forward
legislation to secure a strong and
lasting constitutional settlement
devolving wide-ranging powers to
Scotland and Wales legislation will be
taken forward giving effect to the
Stormont house agreement in Northern
Ireland my government will continue to
work in cooperation with the devolved
administration's on the basis of mutual
respect my government will bring forward
changes to the Standing Orders of the
House of Commons these changes will
create fairer procedures to ensure that
decisions affecting England or England
and Wales can be taken only with the
consent of the majority of members of
parliament representing constituencies
in those parts by united kingdom